the only way i've seen that you can  build confidence is if you surround  yourself with people that are optimistic  it's super hard what i'm about to say to  you cut out as much of the noise and  time with people that are negative and  spend as much time with people that are  positive this isn't where you're at or  what you got this is are the people that  you're sitting with at school on the bus  the shelter here right now are they  saying how shitty everything is or are  they talking about how to get out get  rid of everybody who says it's shitty  there's only one way to build confidence  my guy it's having people that are  reinforcing good things to you